Emily of a Georgia man is asking for
justice more than two months after he
was shot and killed no one has been
arrested or charged in the death of 25
year old Ahmad Arbor II police say he
was chased by two men who suspected him
of a crime armories family says all he
was doing was jogging Omar Villafranca
talked to his mother and the family's
lawyer interview as you will see only on
CBS this morning and he's not with us
because two men followed him while he
was jogging and killed him Ahmad Arbor
II was shot and killed in Brunswick
Georgia we spoke to his mother Wanda
Jones what do you think should have
already happened to these men
an arrest should have been made already
according to neighbors
there had been break-ins in the area are
buried was allegedly spotted at a home
that was under construction before he
began to run 911 calls came in moments
later and he's running right left
according to a police report gregory
McMichael told police he saw arbor e run
by and recognized him from the break-ins
according to the report McMichael and
his 34 year old son Travis grabbed a
shotgun and a pistol and got into their
truck to go after armory once they
caught up to him Gregory McMichael told
investigators armory violently attacked
Travis and the two fought over the
shotgun before Travis shot twice and
killed him the prosecutor who previously
had the case says Travis acted out of
self-defense and the pursuers acted
within the scope of Georgia's citizen's
arrest statute essentially deputizes all
citizens to go out and perform police
functions they did not do that properly
Lee Merritt an attorney for our burries
family says he believes there have not
been any indictments because Gregory
McMichael is a former investigator for
the Brunswick District Attorney's Office
that's why the case was transferred to
the
our County District Attorney there's
more than enough evidence for a case for
murder what do you think those men
should have done they should have waited
until about thought he's arrived they
had already made a call to not with wine
people defending the McMichaels point to
armories previous brushes with the law
hit a shoplifting conviction his mother
said this has nothing to do with what
happened her son is the victim
Gregory McMichael told us since this
case is still being investigated he has
no comment
Tony a lot of questions in that story
Omar thank you very much